et donc me voilà
entouré de mes amis est déterminé à
vivre heureuse jusqu'à la fin des temps
enfin c'est ce que je m'étais imaginé en
fait j'étais bien plus célibataire que
prévu
la ferme soit mais ne nous attardons pas
sur le négatif
il ya beaucoup de positif je suis
totalement folle de ma nouvelle vie
j'occupe le prestigieux poste de
productrice telle est une émission
d'info je cherche quelqu'un de dynamique
pour challenge il est qu'ils aient pas
qui est volontaire tu dois le petit coin
des jets
j'entretiens de bonnes relations avec m
comment vas-tu bien merci à toi je vais
bien ah oui ce qu'ils vous prennent un
grand père un double et ma vie
sentimentale montre des signes
d'amélioration
permettez elle vous va mis à part un
léger incident je suis en sorte je
maîtrise parfaitement la situation pour
un cd
elle exploite regard des nombreux jets
qu'il perd ses marques
il ya moins 50% de chance 50% de chance
vous avez fait ça 3
c'est vous le papa je présume c'est bien
que vous soyez venu c'est un moment
merveilleux et unique taparole x je me
demandais si vous y rendre un petit
service en
c'est vous le papa je présume c'est bien
vous soyez venu c'est c'est un moment
merveilleux et unique